Comencemos por hablar que se espera que
pase con las negociaciones después de
este llamado a consultas se congelarán
los diálogos
el presidente ha llamado consultas a
todo su equipo negociador Se va se
pondrán seguramente algunas líneas rojas
pero la negociación Va a continuar y Va
a continuar es porque se está negociando
en medio de la guerra con las Farc
tuvimos diferentes crisis por ejemplo
tuvimos el asesinato de once militares
sensuales cauca y el proceso de paz aún
así siguió esto que estamos viviendo es
la complejidad de negociar en medio de
la guerra y parte de esta negociación en
medio de la guerra este ataque que hubo
en el municipio del Carmen no es el
único Y es que al eln también el
ejército le estaba atribuyendo sembrar
Minas antipersona en el departamento de
Antioquia en un punto muy cercano a un
campamento donde antiguos combatientes
de las FARC se reintegran a la vida
civil Usted cree que estos ataques son
para presionar al gobierno a pactar un
cese al fuego
hay dos variables ahí por un lado si hay
una presión o estas acciones armadas
buscado presionar a los gobiernos y a
las mesas de negociación pasó lo mismo
con las Farc y históricamente ha pasado
con los diferentes acuerdos en Colombia
pero lo segundo es que sí también hay
una fractura interna dentro del ADN una
cosa son los que están negociando en
México otra es el frente de guerra
Oriental que tiene límite con Venezuela
y que opera desde Venezuela y otra al
frente de guerra occidental que está en
esta área geográfica al occidente del
país en la frontera con Panamá Entonces
el eln no es una organización piramial
jerárquica como lo eran las FARC que
tenía un Mando Único y definido sino que
aquí tienen una autonomía en términos
operacionales cada una de estas unidades
y por eso ni siquiera el eln muchas
veces sabe lo que están haciendo sus
unidades en diferentes zonas del país
bueno Y esta falta de estructura
piramidal como usted la llama también ha
afectado a La tregua que ha sido el
punto más controvertido de los diálogos
Pues recordemos que el presidente afirmó
que se había logrado que se había
logrado y luego él el eln lo desmintió y
en la segunda ronda no lograron pactar
ese cc al fuego Qué tan lejos está ahora
con los recientes ataques
se aleja pero es que hay un principio es
que los peces al fuego bilaterales se
dan es al final de los procesos de paz y
no al comienzo el gobierno
Petro lo que intenta es rápidamente
tener victorias tempranas y poder
disminuir la violencia en el país pero
se veía que eso iba a ser un error
porque pues la presión militar no había
avanzado y esta negociación también
digamos tiene esa lógica que el estado
presiona militarmente y las guerrillas
responden también en términos militares
y lo que se busca es que se escale el
conflicto Entonces el gobierno se
aventuró a darse al fuegos bilaterales
el eln salió al paso y dijo que ellos no
habían negociado nada y y como usted lo
acaba de plantear ni siquiera en este
ciclo de negociación en México que acaba
de terminar se pudo avanzar en ese tema
entonces la guerra continúa y la guerra
de los dos lados ahora las fuerzas
militares acaban de decir que van a
aumentar la acción digamos militar y
operacional contra estas estructuras del
eln entonces esperamos es que avance el
proceso para que así como fue con las
Farc al final sí podamos hablar de un
César fuego bilateral con una
verificación internacional